noch ist es eine Debatte die in der CDU
nicht offen geführt wird wird die
Brandmauer nach links zu halten sein nur
wenige CDUler sind bereit über das
Dilemma zu sprechen mike moring ist es
der frühere Thüringer cduf stürzte weil
er den Dammbruch mit der AFD zuließ nun
rührt er vor der thüringenwahl am
linkstabu H geht eher um die Offenheit
dass man sagt egal wie das ausgeht wir
sind als CDU in der Verantwortung
hinterher eine Lösung zu finden die
stabil ist und die trägt über eine ganze
weahperiode hinweg und das muss man
signalisieren und das Signal aber wir
haben überall Mauern aufgebaut und wir
haben Unvereinbarkeiten definiert dann
bleibt niemand mehr übrig und dann
reicht das nicht in Thüringen könnte mit
den kommenden Landtagswahlen eine
Situation entstehen in der die CDU
zweitstärkste Kraft wird in der jedoch
ohne AFD oder ohne die Linke keine
Regierung zustande kommt mit beiden
Parteien aber hat sich die CDU jede
Kooperation verboten gerade mal 5 Jahre
ist das her die CDU Deutschlands lehnt
Koalitionen und ähnliche Formen der
Zusammenarbeit sowohl mit der
Linkspartei als auch mit der AFD ab
Beschluss des Bundesparteitags und
Parteichef März hält daran fest wir
haben klare Beschlüsse zur AFD und zur
Linkspartei wir kämpfen um Mehrheiten
und wir kämpfen darum diese Umfragen zu
ändern im Thüringer eigsfeld aber halten
Sie die Brandmauer nach links für
weltfremd der
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss ist ein
Beschluss von oben der ist weit weg von
unserer bodenständigen ländlichen
Realität gefasst und darüber müssen jene
nachdenken die den Beschluss gefasst
haben Werner Henning plädiert angesichts
der politischen Lage für Ehrlichkeit
gegenüber den Wählern wenn man sich aber
entscheiden muss zwischen rechts oder
links dann ist ein Blick nach links mir
viel lieber es ist offensichtlich in der
Union ist etwas in Bewegung die
Beharrungskräfte aber sind stark es gibt
einen Diskussionsprozess und ich kann
nur hoffen dass dieser bald
abgeschlossen wird und zwar mit einer
klaren Haltung das bedeutet für mich
auch mit einer klaren Abgrenzung zur
Linkspartei Wolfgang bossbach hält wie
viele in der Partei Profil und SED
Vergangenheit der Linken weiter für
nicht vereinbar mit der CDU es geht
darum ob die linke politische Inhalte
vertritt die mit der Politik und
Überzeugung der Union kompatibel sind
nein und in der Linkspartei gibt es
Format
wo der Verfassungsschutz sagt die
vertreten verfassungsfeindliche Ziele
und Inhalte linkenchef Martin
schirdewann aber will Geschichte und
Schuld seiner Partei gerne ausblenden
die Frage dort die sie stellt ist Bodo
rammelo oder Björn höcke also die linke
oder die AFD und das ist der
entscheidende Punkt und wenn Wolfgang
bsbach in der Vergangenheit festhängen
möchte dann kann er das gern tun aber
wir richten den Blick auf die Gegenwart
fragt man die Ostdeutschen so findet
eine Mehrheit es nicht richtig eine
politische Zusammenarbeit mit der Linken
grundsätzlich
ablehnt das ist so ein Stück weit das
Dilemma den Partei in der Parteizentrale
auf der einen Seite Attraktivität durch
sagen wir mal Verantwortung für das
Ganze zeigen und damit die Brandmauer
aufgeben auf der anderen Seite die
Gefahr politisch zu sehr nach links zu
rücken und damit wieder Stimmen zu
verlieren und das nächste ungeklärte
Verhältnis steht schon vor der Tür kncht
und ihr neues Bündnis ausd dem Stand bei
bundesweit 6% in den Umfragen bei einem
Auftritt in Sachsen gibt die
Parteichefin sich selbstbewusst wir
werden nicht bereit stehen als
Mehrheitsbeschaffer für ein weiterso
wenn die CDU denkt na ja gut wenn nichts
anderes da ist dann gehen wir auf das
BSW zu als machtreserve also das wird
nur funktionieren wenn man dann wirklich
auch mit uns gemeinsam eine andere
Politik macht Mauern einreißen oder im
Osten in die Unregierbarkeit Steuer es
sind diese Fragen denen sich die CDU
stellen
muss und zugeschaltet aus Erft ist mir
jetzt Mario fog der CDU
Landesvorsitzende und Spitzenkandidat
der CDU in Thüringen im kommenden
Wahlkampf schön guten Abend Herr Fogt
guten Abend Frau Ban Herr Fogt wir haben
es gerade im Beitrag gesehen wie die
Stimmung ist Brandmauer nach links
Brandmauer nach rechts manche einer
fühlt sich da regelrecht eingemauert was
sagen sie denn ihren Parteikollegen die
darum bitten dass man eine Öffnung nach
links für den Ernstfall wenig
diskutiert ja die Menschen im Land die
wünschen sich ein Politikwechsel in
Thüringen und der ist mit der Linken
nicht zu machen und das ist auch die
große Mehrheit innerhalb der CDU und
Wähler sollten immer wissen was sie
bekommen und die CDU hat eine klare
Haltung dahinter sind ja keine
politikttischen Spielchen sondern es
geht ja um die Frage was unsere
Grundüberzeugung sind und da ist einfach
die DNA der CDU und das was die Linke
will Meilen weit auseinander was sie
sagen die CDU hab hab da eine klare
Haltung allerdings haben wir gerade
Herrn Bosbach gehört der ja jetzt gerade
viel im Osten unterwegs ist und
Gespräche führt der sagt die Diskussion
gibt es und ihm fehlt die klare Haltung
müssten sie es da nicht eher halten wie
der Landrat in Thüringen der herr
Henning den wir gerade gehört haben und
sagen sie machen sich ehrlich mit wem
würden Sie im Ernstfall eher
Zusammenarbeiten mit der AFD oder mit
der Linken nein es ist aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen genau richtig
zu sagen wir machen keine Koalition mit
den Linken und auch keine mit der AFD
und die auseinander etzung dieses Jahres
die lautet in Thüringen wie in vielen
anderen Ländern des Ostens entweder CDU
oder AFD und ich glaube dass es wichtig
ist dass wir das begreifen die CDU ist
das einzig demokratische Bollwerk was
eben auch verhindern kann dass unser
Land zurückfällt und die Linke ist kein
Politikangebot in Berlin oder das was
wir in Erfurt erleben die Menschen haben
das satt und die wollen auch
ehrlicherweise keine Politik taktischen
Diskussionen die wollen ihre Probleme
gelöst wissen und das kriegen sie weder
noch in Berlin ob man eine Politik
taktische Diskussion will ist die eine
Frage aber die Zahlen sprechen auch für
sich das Bollwerk CDU das sie gerade
nennen hat in Thüringen momentan in den
Umfragen ungefähr 20% das wird nicht
reichen um alleine zu regieren sie
werden Partner brauchen und da muss man
sich eben dann doch unterhalten wenn sie
sagen es gibt keine Koalition mit der
Linken würden Sie denn für eine
Regierungsfähigkeit sich von der Linken
tolerieren lassen Frau Ban ich kämpfe
jetzt in einem Landtagswahlkampf dafür
dass wir eine funktionierende Mehrheit
in in der Demokratischen Mitte bekommen
und ich habe gerade in der letzten Woche
eine Landratswahl gehabt wo wir wirklich
es geschafft haben als CDU in der höcke
Hochburg zu gewinnen und deswegen weiß
ich na ja ja aber trotzdem ist es uns
gelungen und ich glau anderen Parteien
deswegen noch einmal die Nachfrage
hätten sie denn im Ernstfall die
Unterstützung ihres Parteivorsitzenden
Friedrich märz für eine Tolerierung nein
Friedrich märz und ich sind einer
Meinung wenn es darum geht wir gehen
jetzt in einen Wahlkampf wo wir als CDU
ich will es noch mal sagen als
oppositionsp Partei mittlerweile 5%
Punkte vor dem linken
Ministerpräsidenten stehen und wir
wollen in der Auseinandersetzung mit der
AFD durch eine inhaltliche
Auseinandersetzung
Punkten und damit eben auch noch eine
stabile Mehrheit in der Mitte
hinbekommen und ich glaube dass das
möglich ist ich finde nicht dass wir
jetzt schon im Februar vergeben sollten
wie die Ergebnisse im September aussehen
sondern es lohnt sich wirklich mit den
Menschen im Gespräch zu sein und das
zeigen do auch die Demonstrationen auf
der Straße es bewegt sich was in
Deutschland und die CDU kann wenn sie
das solide vorträt und sich nicht in
diesen Politik taktischen Spielchen
ergeht tatsächlich gewinnen die
Demonstrationen auf der Straße richten
sich vor allem gegen Rechtsextremismus
jetzt ist Thüringen ein echter
Sonderfall bei ihnen kann es passieren
dass im dritten Wahlgang ein
Rechtsextremist gewählt wird wenn es
hart auf hart kommt denn im dritten
Wahlgang braucht bei ihnen in Thüringen
jemand der Ministerpräsident werden
möchte nur noch die einfache Mehrheit
sie könnten das verhindern wenn sie sich
unter anderem mit den Linken vorher über
einen Gegenkandidaten für den Ernstfall
verständigen wären sie dazu bereit Frau
banneri ich will genau das verhindern
und deswegen habe ich auch schon
öffentlich gesagt dass die CDU im
dritten Wahlgang auf jeden Fall
kandidieren wird und damit die Chance
eben auch steigert dass das nicht
passieren wird das Wichtige ist
allerdings dass wir auch klar sind in
der Frage mit welchen Themen wir die AFD
Stellen ich bin derjenige der björn
höcke rausgefordert hat und gesagt hat
jemand der Europa der die EU sterben
sehen will der ist eine Gefahr für den
Wohlstand und die Wirtschaft in unserem
Land und diese sachliche
Auseinandersetzung in mit aller Härte
vorgetragen die führt am Ende dazu dass
Menschen uns das Vertrauen schenken
werden und nur so wird funktionieren
sagt der CDU Landesvorsitzende in
Thüringen herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch Frau B schönen Dank schönen
Abend